[Music]
many gun rights advocates fear a new
attack on the second amendment with the
new government in washington
some are taking a page from their
liberal opponents
and applying it to the gun issue
national correspondent william leicester
tonight from los angeles on the concept
of second amendment
sanctuaries won't stop
until we beat the nra president biden's
plan to rewrite america's gun laws
makes gun owners nervous i'm doing
everything on my power
in office or out of office to get those
assault weapons off the street which
i've done
once already and to get those clips that
have
multiple bullets in them not for sale if
the feds want to come in and start
taking people down
for having a high capacity magazine
we're not going to have any part in that
state rep leo basuchi wants to make
arizona a second amendment sanctuary
state
banning the use of state money or
manpower to enforce
any federal law or regulation that
violates the right to bear arms
this bill is saying they can do what
they want in d.c but
we're not going to have our law
enforcement spend resources to help them
arrest law-abiding citizens who are gun
owners
four states and more than 400 mostly red
cities and towns passed measures
declaring themselves
gun sanctuaries modeled after blue state
rules that protect
illegal immigrants from federal law
there is no substance behind this
it's theater it's spectacle while
opponents call gun sanctuary laws
symbolic they do fear
their effect it is anti-american
and deeply troubling that anyone would
run for office and push something like
this they're denying
support for citizens in their state who
are
impacted by gun violence gun advocates
fear
local police will be enlisted to enforce
a national gun registry
confiscate guns and limit the sale of
ammunition
opponents say courts not states define
the second amendment
but some fear biden will issue rules and
regs bypassing gun protections
last week governor abbott said he
supports making texas
a second amendment sanctuary state brett
william thank you a new york state judge
is rejecting a bid by the national rifle
association to dismiss
put on hold or transfer a lawsuit by new
york's attorney general
seeking its dissolution the decision
comes
just days after the nra filed for
bankruptcy protection and said it
planned to reincorporate
in the more gun-friendly state of texas
after 150 years
in new york